hello everyone and welcome to round 2 of
the 2018 Norway championship when I
decided which game to show I thought
it'd be nice to check out a game between
Sergei hurricane and Magnus Carlsen as
if we look at the final standings of
2017 Norway championship
some of you may not know but Magnus
Carlsen and Sergei kurakin had last
place and second to last place so three
and a three and a half hour nine for
Kerrigan and four out of nine for Magnus
Carlsen so definitely a terrible
tournament for both of them especially
since you know Carlson's its home
territory advantage or in this case a
disadvantage and you know in 2016 those
two these two were battling it out for
the title of world champion as car cane
was the 2016 World Chess Championship
challenger so definitely an interesting
game and you'll see that Magnus Carlsen
really prepares a a mean line with the
black pieces and you will see just how
far preparation goes in these high-level
matches so we don't have I did I did
find one photo of this of this encounter
there's kurakin on the left
Mikasa on the right car can already
played his first movie for and Carson is
waiting for someone to take his photo
before actually make his first move now
that's that's a good good psychology
there so we have E 4 E 5 Knight to f3
and Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 so the
rule opus is on the board just just a
second we have 86 more fees defense
Bishop to a4 we have Knight to f6
Carrick in castles and here already a
big surprise for Sergey Kerrigan you
know he played this position plenty of
times and he knows Carson played this
position plenty of times and the cross
and always goes Bishop to e7 but here
for the first time ever Carlsen decided
to go Bishop to c5 and I surprised it
with the black pieces we have c3 castles
by Carlson and d4 now and better back to
a7
exchanging here doesn't really give you
all that much to simply give white too
strong of a center without really
gaining anything for it
you can even push a 5 and end the d5 and
black black will already run into a lot
of trouble here so after the four Bishop
to e7 D captures on e5 Knight captures
on e4 and Queen to d5 now attacking the
knight on e4
nice to see five attacking the bishop on
a4 Bishop to c2 and not nice to e7 Queen
to d1 and now you can see that kirkenes
the bishops are much more active than
Carlson Carlson does have a nice dark
square Bishop eyeing that f2 pawn but
the light square bishop still isn't
really developed and if Carson is not
careful you know you can easily see an
attack being developed here so Carson
goes for d5 immediately we have a
capture some d5 Queen captures on d5
Carson offers an exchange of Queen's
Queen captures see captures and rook to
d1 so this is move 14 and you know a lot
of lines could have been played you know
this is it's not like it's some kind of
a force line that leads the disposition
and here a huge surprise for Sergei
kurakin of course he was expecting roof
to d8 simply defending the pawn but the
Carlsen goes for Bishop to g4 later in
an interview Carson will say that it's a
very very you know vicious engine line
he he he found and he prepared it for
this game so what's the idea the idea is
of course you're black is given up a
pawn but the the question is why is
black giving up a pawn well Kirk in
grabbed it rook captures on d6 here
cross and played Bishop to f5 and this
was the idea first Bishop to g4 with
threats of capturing the night and the
doubling White's pawns and the knight
was pinned as the rook was on beat 1 and
now only now when the rook has captured
the pawn on d6 Bishop to f5 and now
White has to make a choice you're
attacking his Bishop on c2 and either
White will capture and this was of
course Carson's plan if Bishop captures
then Knight captures
comes with an attack on the rook so you
don't have to move the rook somewhere
rook to d1 seems like the best idea but
now comes Luke 8 to d8 and now you see
why it's problem all of whites pieces
are undeveloped okay the rook is the
world but black is already threatening
to simply capture it and after you
exchange again white is white is
completely undeveloped and for the price
of that one pawn black has extreme
activity here and if white is white
hopes to survive this position he will
have to give back material with a 92 you
don't want to allow rogue d1 but then
nice to d3 is coming wood with an attack
on the f2 pawn there is no way to defend
upon the bishop is also attacking it so
Carson would equalizing material but he
would keep a much more active position
so this was his idea when he played this
Bishop to g4 and rushed back to a5 idea
but kurakin doesn't go for this he
doesn't capture and of course he does
have to defend his bishop he plays knife
to a3 we have nice to e4 by Carlsen now
attacking the f2 pawn and now you see
the idea behind the pawn sacrifice here
cousin wins the bishop pair so Bishop
captures Bishop captures and now rook
back to d1 Knight to f5
we have knife to c4 rook to e8 Bishop to
e3 offering an exchange of bishops and
now comes Bishop captures and here a
Corrigan could could maybe try and try
and bring his King over try something
else
but his rook is still undeveloped the
bishop is still undeveloped and here
carotene decides to simply give up his
extra pawn but across and will also be
the profit of the bishop repair so we
have Bishop to e3 Bishop captures Knight
captures Knight captures pawn captures
and now of course Carson does have a
bishop against tonight but he's still
upon down so he can try to outmaneuver
something here but the engine completely
agrees with Carson's
response here so I guess always well
bunch of characters on f3 pawn cap
and now rook captures on e3 cross and
equalized in material and he does have a
better pawn structure it's two point
islands against three point islands but
on the other hand kirkenes rook will be
more active as he immediately plays look
to d7 this comes with an attack on the
b7 pawn so rook to b8 and now rook a to
d1 now Kirk in doubles up on the D file
already threatening rook to b8 with
check so King comes to f8 now comes King
to have to attacking cousins rook rook
to e7 and now rook to e8 check rook to
e8 row capture some b8 rook captures and
again rook to d7 so across and I have a
better pawn structure but call a
Kirkenes rook is much more active King
to e8 attacking the rook we have rocked
the c7 and now you can't approach the
rook because you have to keep an eye on
your honor King side pawns so b5 by
Carson and the engine once again agrees
with him we have looked to c6 now
attacking the a6 pawn and now rook to e8
see for breaking-up that that small
chain on the Queen side King to d7 and
now first she captures on b5 Punk after
some b5 and now rook to b6 rook captures
rook cap for some b5 now the b2 point is
defended and the material is once again
equal now Carlsen does have one point
Ireland against a three point islands
but still it's it's it's impossible to
push for advantage here I rocked way for
was played now comes King g3
rugby for check King to b7 check a route
to b7 check King g6 rook to b6 check
King f5 or up to b5 check and Hereafter
King e6 rugby 6 King a five-run b5 and
King e6 it was a three-fold repetition
and the players basically agreed to a
draw so a very nice game even though
even though it's a draw but it's not
like like a you know like a death draw
from the start they did play it out
until move 41 time control was reached
and then the players agreed that there
there is no point in pushing this
especially since Carlson won his first
game with the white
he doesn't mind and mind an early draw
in round two and he will push for
advantage in round three once again with
the white pieces so yeah it's a very
nice game between these two rivals and
it's very interesting here at this
moment where this rook to d1 was played
and instead of this rook to work to d8
Carlsen surprising with a Bishop to g4
and like we said move 14 and this is how
far preparation goes on in these
high-level games so yeah Kuryakin didn't
go for it but yeah Bishop to a5 it's
like Carson said in an interview after
the game once you once you see it it
really makes sense but finding this over
the board very very unlikely you know
for a for a human so a car key didn't
didn't fall for this for this idea he
found Knight 283 refuting Carson's idea
so a very nice very nice game by add the
Minister of Defence as well against this
nicely prepared variation so yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Bartos Barbic offski
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
was you soon
most likely with with a game or two from
my 2013 candidates tournament series but
then tomorrow after round 3 of Norway
championship continues then I will cover
that of course as well so yeah I thank
you all and I will see you soon